voici donc nouveau carrelage qui a été
refait puisque l'ancien se décoller tout
nouveau tout beau et complètement
aberrant un décollement du carrelage en
raison de malfaçons par l'entreprise
d'origine condamné à payer 500 mille
euros
alors quitte à être fermé pendant trois
mois le centre aquatique du lac s'est
offert un grand lifting à un million
quatre cent mille euros
l'occasion d'optimiser l'espace et de
rénover une structure vieillissante à
l'ouverture de l'équipement il ya dix
ans cet équipement était français pour
200 à 250 mille visiteurs par an s'avère
que dans la réalité l'équipement
accueille entre 450 et 500 milles
baigneurs par an ce qui est aussi un
facteur de vieillissement accéléré je
dirais de l'équipement parmi ces
améliorations une zone de déchaussage
pour plus d'accessibilité de nouveaux
casiers électronique un espace bien être
complètement réaménagé avec douche
écossaise terrasse et banias russe
tous les carrelages des plages des fonds
piscine rénovée ainsi que deux nouvelles
caisses pour mieux gérer les périodes
d'affluence
là les enfants ils sont pas tombé une
seule fois donc ça change et c'est
beaucoup mieux que c'est assez positif
c'est assez grand et plus spacieux j'ai
traité vestiaire était très agréable les
couleurs sont sympathiques il ya plus
d'espacé qu'avant qu'ils sont vraiment
bien ils ont vraiment bien d'améliorer
la piscine je trouve ça vraiment top la
piscine a donc ouvert ses portes
aujourd'hui pour l'espace bien-être il
faudra attendre samedi prochain les
tarifs restent inchangés toujours 5
euros 30 l'entrée et bientôt un système
de billetterie sera disponible sur
internet